welcome to this video playing you
hands-on okay Johannsson that's a pretty
high rating Cara dig you on sun from
oops a las piñas one of those money
accounts that's not this guy it's not
even having federating I think I looked
that up once or some other guy but
definitely a strong player okay I
noticed I've got my flag back actually I
found the setting I'm not sure how it
got deleted in the first place okay yeah
he's playing this line now that's very
uncommon but I have forgotten wine
I think in former times they went before
here but I'm not sure that this is still
the the prescribed anti dote okay let's
do this but I really I'm really unsure
okay so he took on c3 yeah that's quite
interesting let's see how to play that
I'd like to play night maybe 92 putting
pressure there on the pawns but that
would hamper my bishop maybe it goes to
a 3 yeah I'm not sure about that
complicated structure I'm a bit
surprised that it took on c3 so quickly
nothing that feels very very natural to
me to do that voluntarily but maybe
maybe it's okay what I try with a 4 is
make it up in more difficult for him to
play be five let's go here and Bishop a
three years also i move that i wanted to
prepare within right on d 2 that's it
said that's a that's a drastic measure
hmm the cheek what is he doing there
night takes hmm if I go 'if I've he
probably plays F for that that does not
look too great okay it takes with the
bishop
k rupee 5s my idea hiding for d5 maybe
you can go 95 now but i have not see
form that should be at least okay for me
v 7s hanging also now i can take be
seven but there's a check on d5 and then
night XD for this is a problem if i go
back he has be five in fact
hmm King stinks
and he has to be five remarkable okay
maybe I'm missing something but I have
to be quick their check so probably
review one checking this night they're
only seven no cake you will get and b5
but hmm that's a way to prevent that i
think that i don't i don't really trust
his position here very much but I don't
see at the moment how to exploit it he
will get in b5 night to e3
not sure about that quite tricky with
tricky position
how is he not exchanging Queen a five or
something I go d 5 then maybe it was
wrong to take actually opening opening
up there they found I'm not sure I think
I'm okay yeah very much but I spent
quite quite some time down here how to
play that night bishop this nice here
anyway for rookie 7 let's get this going
no g5 maybe this is a this is an
annoying move no it doesn't do it
g6 night h6 checkmate that would be cute
but that's not going to happen I don't
have much time I really don't want to
draw difficult it's difficult to avoid
really yeah come on yeah I 40 seconds
that's a shame white is clearly better
and yeah I can go rookie to there maybe
I should have done that or rookie 6 yeah
i was a bit cautious there admit with
repeating so it's a nice very nice
position there was a strange game with
f5 and so on that that's really kind of
surprising this move and it's always a
bit tricky to play against those
somewhat fishy accounts here that don't
really add up to anything yeah it's an
old account dad has a fake name in there
yeah and when this is no no no there's
no underrated player with 2,600 and the
five-minute pool so um it's a kind of a
strange account you always think is he
cheating or whatever okay probably not
as I gained a draw but term it's always
a bit strange to play against those
accounts ticks ticks yeah bishop is
Bishop you won yes that makes sense
cheeks yeah I know he went a 6 funny
move but I cannot take them because of
the check check and this thing that's
not troubling like much and maybe can
play the Queen image well that's sort of
what I wanted chess is probably better
here okay that's interesting the
computer wants to take
this this and an 85 that sets a cool
move Queen takes as night c4 and night
cheeks movie 528 Queen f5 with a good
position now that's a nice move but
Bishop e7 is a very counterintuitive
rookie one looks very normal I compounds
to go f1 now and then I def 133 m f1
looked very weakening but I see the
point not f 1 is 3 is quite bad quite
bad for black ok I had this idea that
was preserving an advantage pretty
pretty clearly big stakes yeah why does
constantly better one point something
according to the cough so I cannot
really blame myself very much there I I
can continue their of course now and
should I happy should be five as a good
move yeah that's a good move being at
the rope here now white is much better
here of course had the deep on this is
nicely protected and this is a weakness
but well I got a little bit scared
because of the time and it's the first
game of the session that's always a bit
like to get something on the scoreboard
ok well thanks for watching